hi today we're looking at language
models are unsupervised multitask
learners by Alec Radford Jeffery woo
reven child
David Lewin Daria amadai and Ilya
sutskever from open AI this paper has
generated a bit of hype in the last few
days so I wanted to go over it basically
take a look and take a look at the
surrounding let's say controversy
so let's actually have a look at the
blog post that openly I released along
with this with this paper they say we've
trained a large scale on supervised
language model which generates coherent
paragraphs of text achieves state of the
art performance on many language
modeling benchmarks and performs
rudimentary reading comprehension
machine translation question answering
and summarization all without task
specific training so this sounds quite
suspicious at the beginning but we're
actually gonna have to look at how they
do this like it sounds really good being
able to do rudimentary translation
without any training on translation
itself just learning a language model
but this is this has been continuing a
trend in recent kind of time where we
see that the better your language model
gets the the better basically the your
model gets on all these kind of language
tasks alright they they go into this and
we'll see how they do it so basically
what they've done is they've taken a
kind of a bigger data set of language
model of language model data set which
is about 40 gigabytes of internet text
they say this is here on the top and so
it's one of the largest kind of text
data sets there is unsupervised and they
also taken one of the largest model
language models so they has their their
largest transformer based model has 1.5
billion parameters so they take huge
amount of data huge model that
brainless on they trained the model on
the data and what comes out is like
giant super language model that is able
to perform all these cool tasks so here
they have it like a bit of a sample so
what they can do is they can basically
so the way along which model works is
you always try to predict the next word
based on what you've already seen so you
kind of query it by giving it some
starting words and it needs to continue
the text from there
so here system prompt on top PC in shock
and finding scientists discovered a herd
of unicorns living in a remote
previously unexplored Valley in the
Andes Mountains
even more surprising to the researcher
the fact that the unicorns spoke perfect
English and then the model continues the
scientists named their population the
population after their distinctive horn
over it's even a corn these four horns
silver white unicorns were previously
unknown to science now after almost two
centuries the mystery of what sparked
this odd phenomena monana spineless
solved I mean you can even read this
it's really really coherent text and
it's quite surprising and I think it's
like slightly cherry picked but still
that the fact that I'm always able to do
this is unprecedented especially like
since it's like a general language model
not specific to the task of continuing
news articles about unicorns or anything
so yeah they're going to they're going
to these findings we'll see them in the
paper and they they also say that yeah
they can they can now do these all these
kind of tasks like question answering
reading comprehension in zero shot
fashion all right so at the end here
they say what it's capable of so let's
say AI writing assistance more capable
dialog agents on suppress translation
blah blah blah
they also say a few kind of
let's say bad implications generally
generate misleading news articles
impersonate others online automate the
production of abusive or faked content
to post on social media automate the
production of spam or phishing content
they liken it to a system called deep
fakes which generates really
well-crafted let's say videos of people
so that the the kind of they frame it in
a way as this could be used for
dangerous things and they say they
aren't releasing they're only releasing
the small version of GPT - along with
the code they're not releasing the data
set training code or the GPT - this is
the big model the model of weights right
and they do this they cite safety
concerns so I mean the community
basically is is going nuts over this the
statement this decision not release
basically the code or the model or the
dataset to the - to the world and so if
you search on Twitter for cheap hashtag
GPT - then everyone basically has an
opinion of whether or not this is a good
thing or not apart from people testing
it out so they've given access to like a
selected set of journalists to an API
where they can query the model so there
there are some samples flying around but
basically people people are just
debating whether or not this is a good
thing or not and I mean it's just
hilarious - to go along with this and to
just read all the other people having
opinions I mean I've given my opinion as
well just chime in it's a fun it's fun
right especially like
this post here on reddit
machine-learning says should I release
my in this model or keep it closed
source fearing malicious use today I
trained at 23,000 lair Reznik got a 99
percent 6 percent accuracy and I'm this
I love to share the model but if hear it
being used maliciously a lot of it is
history documents but eruptions what are
your thoughts this is an essence I mean
in essence it's it's that right it's
like yeah come on so I can just give my
opinion upfront it's it's I think a lot
of a lot of things came together here
and I think that this being open AI
being kind of this initiative and he's
never been there before they're not an
academic institution institution they're
not a company but still they you know
they're researchers they want to have a
career so there's lots of pressures on
them there's pressure to further publish
so I think that that's kind of an
underlying motivation to not release
your model and your code and your
dataset is you actually you know there's
a lot of work in this and you actually
might want to get more than one paper
out of it so keeping these things to
yourself is basically a surefire
guarantee you're gonna get another two
three four or five papers out of this
data or a model or whatever it's also a
good way to kind of generate press if
you basically say oh we're not releasing
but we have this really good model and
there's there's one thing on Twitter
right I mean you can't probably can't
find it but says like step one my model
is state of the art step 2 my model is
state of the art but generalize is
better to other tasks step 3 my model
does the same thing but with fewer
parameters and step 4 my model is so
good I can't even talk about it
yeah so so basically I think a lot of
things came together that this is press
generating the pressure to to create
more kind of papers out of it and
general genuinely security concerns that
I think being open the eye and the
opening I kind of was established as a
way to let's say did demo like their
statutes pretty clearly say we want to
open the eye and research it and ethical
use and you have backers like Elon Musk
that talk all the time about kind of
safety related issues in AI I think
there's a lot of pressure on these
people to with everything they do
basically have an ethical component all
right so to every everything they do is
kind of scrutiny to this does this have
a fickle implications and where can we
basically stand out from the rest of the
community by doing something it doesn't
need to be more effort it just needs to
be different with an ethical reason
behind the reasoning behind it and this
I think this is it I think there's a lot
of things coming together I don't I
don't think anyone like maliciously
thought oh this you know we're gonna do
this it's gonna generate so much press
or I don't think anyone actively thought
ah well just keep it secret we're gonna
get so much more papers out of it I
think that the reasoning was there's a
lot of you know a lot of pressure to do
this ethical things when they're just
there's not if you think about it it's
yeah it's a good language model and it
can generate text but you can also hire
you know people to generate text to
generate fake news to do fishing and
spam it's just a bit more efficient now
right and yeah so it's it's
unprecedented that you don't you don't
release this research kind of Cold War
style so it's it's not really dangerous
to release this
and it's just delaying the inevitable
basically but I think that the pressure
the pressure was on and they made a
decision that they thought was in line
with their values and I think the this
just neatly aligns with the underlying
the other benefits to them that yeah all
right so let's dive into the paper the
paper is actually not you know to too
much content there or they basically say
so far is that a lot of lot of these
kind of papers on these tasks they they
say the dominant approached creating mo
systems is to collect the data set of
training examples demonstrate correct
behavior training system to imitate test
its performance on in iid samples so
they basically say the there's kind of
the single task training on single
domain datasets is a major contributor
to the lack of generalization of the
earth and current system so they
basically say these language systems
they don't generalize like a QA system
might be trained on a QA task but it you
know has nothing to do if the task is
basically a little bit different and
even in multi task learning and they say
multi task learning is a promising
framework but also it's kind of saying
it's still nascent and there's only very
few different tasks right to do so they
basically say you need basically a big
big unsupervised model and it will
implicitly learn all of the kind of
special tasks yeah so they say there
there are approaches that basically
basically learn these language models
but then still require supervised
training
so basically fine-tuning this has been
the this is for example the bird paper
we discussed in the last video to two
videos ago that learns a giant language
model but then just fine-tuning for each
of these tasks and gets really well what
they want to do here is basically simple
we learn a language model and then
investigate whether or not the language
model can perform downstream tasks in a
zero shot setting that means without any
parameter or architectural modifications
or no fine-tuning right so what they do
so basically what a language model is if
for those who don't know it's it's if
you have a sequence of texts let's say a
b c d e these are words let's ignore
actual words the cat sat on the mat and
so on and you and you a language model
is you kind of remove the end of the
sentence at some point and ask the model
what comes next
right that's a language model I mean
there's different kinds of language
models specific language ones but that's
the basic the basic thing so the the you
just ask the model what's next so you
can you can do a lot of unsupervised
training because you don't need to label
data set for this you simply need to
text corpus and that's basically all
they do they use transformers which
we've also discussed in attention is all
you need paper so if you don't know what
transformers are go back and look at
that yeah all right so basically they
say a lot of these special tasks like
translation and the question answering
can be framed in language model way for
example if you simply input if if this
is your text translate to french and
then eat the english text and then the
french text right and then at at test
time basically you leave away the french
text you simply ask the language model
what comes next
right if in its input is translate to
French in the English text this is the
translation framed as a language model
task because you can specify the task
that the language show has to do also as
language so this is quite this is quite
an interesting approach and one they
exploit here and they basically say well
since in a large and diverse corpus of
web pages that they collect here some
there is gonna be some websites that
basically all do translation from
English to French and the model can
learn from that so here in this
paragraph they basically list examples
of naturally occurring demonstrations of
English to French and French to English
translation found throughout the
training dataset so basically this is
this is how the model could learn let's
just look at one I hate the word perfume
versus it's somewhat better in French
puffs right so did that there's a way in
just an unsupervised setting where the
language model could learn right if you
just cross out this word puff on at the
end and you just ask a model what comes
next
right the model sees I hate the word
perfume versus it's somewhat better in
French Pierre :
then the model has to put something
there and the most logical continuation
is to put the French word for perfume
right so that that's kind of how they
frame translation and these other tasks
in language model way all right so they
talk about the training data set which
is a major component here they say they
make a new training dataset because all
of the current ones aren't sufficient
they say most problems source of
diversity nearly unlimited Texas web
scripts such as common crawl while these
archives are many orders of magnitude
larger than current language modeling
data sets they have significant data
quality issues so to say content are
mostly unintelligible and so on so they
basically describe here how they scrape
a new web scrape which emphasizes
document quality they go on reddit
basically and scrape all outbound links
from reddit the
have received at least three karma which
means that it you know three up votes
for a post of a link which basically
means that three humans agreed that this
was a good link so so they that's that's
how they collect the data set the
resulting dataset web stack web text
contains the text subset of the forty
five million links they even kind of
clean this and scrape it down and remove
some stuff and they they end up with a
large corpus right and then they talk
about how they represent the input which
is by pair encoding style it's not
exactly by parent coding it's a bike
pairing coding inspired encoding we we
won't make a video about this by itself
because it's really interesting but
basically it's you can think of it as
tokenization and pre-processing right
then they say they they show their
models so architecture hyper parameters
basically these are these are their
models this is the smallest one this
second smallest one they say it's the
same size as Bert so the the language
model by Google that we've looked at and
then the largest one 1.5 billion
parameters and that's huge
and yeah they say it's ten times larger
than the previous so the first one is
their previous model and this now is
this distant at GPT to model that that
gets all these these nice results so
they do experiments first they do
experiments on language modeling itself
right so they train on their on their
corpus and then they evaluate on a bunch
of other language modeling
corpus so these up here are language
modeling Corp corpuses and and the state
of the art isn't this row and then you
just look at basically the bottom row
compared to their largest model this is
perplexity and where it says ppl and the
I think this here is accuracy
so perplexity lower is better which you
can you can see here the previous
state-of-the-art was 39 on week text two
they get to 18 with accuracy obviously
higher is better so the kind of previous
accuracy in Lambada was 59 they get to
63 basically improve everything except
for this one building word purpose and
they are they also explain why they say
this is the most heavily pre-processed
text and so on so that they basically
yeah they basically are really good at
language modeling even though they train
on a different data set that's the point
right the point is they train on their
own corpus and then they go and just
evaluate on a test set of these of these
new of these new tasks and they become
better basically than the models that
trained on the training data set of that
particular task all right so they do a
number of further experiments where they
basically show that the model has now
learned kind of implicitly learned a
number of different tasks so let's look
at for example summarization this just
want to show an example of how you can
do this so summarization summarization
task is you get a long text you need to
produce a short text and that short text
is then compared to short texts that
humans wrote when the task was to
summarize
they're long texts and you get points on
how much your text overlaps with these
human texts that so they they say we
test Jeep t2 ability to perform
summarization want to CNN and tail email
data set to induce summarization here's
what I find interesting we add the text
TL DR after the article and generate a
hundred tokens right then they they say
they need to reduce repetition and so on
but basically this this this is right
this is the way you can frame
summarization by text input so I find
this just a kind of a really nice way to
think about these problems the fact that
instructions of the task can be given as
text this is a very nice example here so
basically you put as input you put the
entire article right and so you here is
the the CNN article blah blah blah it's
super long right and then here you put
TL DR which is for those who don't know
it's too long didn't read so people use
this this phrase to indicate that then
they will write a short summary of
whatever was before here they will
either put this at the beginning or at
the end of a long text right to to say
to people okay if you don't want to read
all this just read this down here gives
you the gist of it which is exactly
summarization so if you then take this
away and ask the language model what's
here right basically throughout the
training corpus the language model will
have encountered such pieces of text
with a tldr in it and the language model
might have learned that whatever is down
here is a short version of whatever is
up here and thereby if you then ask
language model what comes next
here right the language model might
learn
I need to summarize whatever is above
and that's the my best shot at
completing that answering the question
what comes next
and yeah so they get you know
surprisingly good results from from this
so they say on the commonly reported
rouge 112 metrics to generate the
summers only begin to approach the
performance of classic neural base lines
just barely outperform selecting three
random sentences from the article but
but still it while qualitatively the
generations resemble summaries they
often focus on recent content from the
article in few specific details so this
is kind of a task where it kind of
worked but not really but I just find it
it's really interesting that that it
kind of how they frame the task and how
this can still so it still kind of works
and that's the the gist here in all of
these tasks is also with like
translation they obviously don't get
near the performance of a system
specifically trained to do this task but
they all also always say it kind of
works right it's sort of sort of it
learned something and their entire point
of this paper is to say well look yeah
Det the diversity of tasks the model is
able to perform and I would say kind of
perform in a zero shot setting suggests
that high-capacity models trying to
maximize the likelihood of a
sufficiently varied text corpus begin to
learn how to perform a surprising amount
of tasks without the need for explicit
supervision so yeah the entire point is
if we train on such varied data that can
that spans the entire range of human
language expression the the kind of
tasks we want these systems to do will
be learned implicitly so basically it
points to
let's get an even bigger corpus let's
get even bigger models and we might get
even better unsupervised zero shop way
in these kind of special tasks and
general language understanding alright
so that was basically it I've jumped
over a lot of points but I encourage you
to look into this to look into the
specific experiments they're really
interestingly how they framed things and
give just just shout your opinion around
about whether or not the publishing is a
good thing or not it's really funny I
love it
and without - have a good day